out of all the updates coming to
Counter-Strike 2 so far one stands far
and above the most game-altering and
controversial the new smoke grenades
sure they look cool as hell but they are
so much more than a pretty face they're
going to change the way CS has played
forever and this is how
smoke grenades have always been an
integral part of Counter-Strike your aim
and flicks are only going to get you so
far sooner or later unfortunately you're
gonna have to learn some smokes they are
huge throughout the Counter-Strike
series smokes have all pretty much
operated the same you throw them in the
Obscure a fixed amount of vision for a
specific period of time and if you're at
a level where your opponents can even
remotely hit their shots you're gonna
need a smoke grenade to do just about
anything unlike other Shooters when you
die in Counter-Strike not only are you
out of the round but you potentially
impact your entire team's economy so
protecting your life with a smoke screen
is invaluable and its graphical Fidelity
got better over the years and strat's
got generally more complex the
usefulness of smoke grenades hit an
all-time high in CS go
got for us here is this across smoke
just a standard old
oh my goodness okay hang on everyone
witness him
okay
is that a hinge no way no no no no no no
no no no
ban him right now however with the
upcoming release of CS2 the way that
smokes have historically operated has
changed completely and many believe it's
going to cause a massive shift in The
Meta but before we get into the
potential ramifications we need to talk
about what the hell makes these smokes
so different well from valve's original
video on the subject they classified
their new smokes as being quote
volumetric objects that live in the
world in layman's terms it means that
the smokes are now going to mutate to
the environment objects and players they
can shift around walls and morph into
nooks and crannies it's Wicked
in their video valve also showed how a
smoke would theoretically react in a
very specific environment like this
donut thingy and that got me thinking
one nuke vents I'm very curious to see
how much a single smoke will fill up
that whole area and more generally
speaking how exactly that spot is going
to get played now two I can't wait to
see what crazy map creators come up
with and more importantly if valve
releases any maps that have complex
spaces that can take advantage of these
new smokes anyway next to all those very
obvious differences are a ton of more
technical changes that are going to make
smoke usage even more Dynamic and thanks
to war owl we have a very good breakdown
of what those things are although
utility trajectory is still the same a
smoke grenade's plume is now taller
wider and lasts three and a half seconds
longer than they did in go and as we've
seen a ton of people already try out CS2
has included a trajectory tool to use in
practice mode to help people learn
smokes even going so far as to add a
picture-in-picture to illustrate exactly
where it will land on top of that it was
confirmed that CS2 basically has no more
sky boxes at least none that can be
interacted with this means that smokes
can now hypothetically be thrown end to
end and that's just going to raise the
bar on how creative people can be with
their lineups make sure you get your
protractors ready because as soon as the
Nerds get a hold of this beta it's game
over now although many people were
hoping for a dedicated jump bind from
valve they won't be including one that
being said valve did say that jump
throws are going to be easier now and
you don't need a jump bind and War I'll
pretty much confirm this in a test there
was some controversy about CS2 not
adding in a native jump throw bind I
think adding it in is a good idea since
it's such a big part of the game but for
my calculations you get a 200
millisecond window to hit your jump
throw without a bind that's definitely
doable by now you might be wondering
Devin what are you talking about these
smokes are awesome what's so
controversial about them and how are
they going to change the meta well if
you've seen what valve showed in the
second half of their video you would
know that smokes can now be dissipated
for a period of time with bullets and
grenades when I first saw this my jaw
nearly hit the floor not only have I
never really seen a game do anything
like this before but it's going to
change the way the game is played
forever because already people are
showing exactly what strats you can pull
off with this new mechanic door here we
go
now how exactly is this going to change
the meta well let's start with the
obvious being able to blow away a smoke
for a period of time is going to open up
an entirely new aspect of the game
previously if the enemy team smoked
something off properly knowing what they
were doing was basically a guessing game
but now people on both sides of the
smoke need to be prepared for someone to
throw a cheeking Aid and get that party
started
you guys ready you guys ready
go it's on this kid
I already got it homies next to that if
you were a veteran of Cs go you would
know that one ways and smoke spamming
has been pretty goddamn overpowered
although it was impossible to know
exactly where the enemy was on the other
side of the smoke if you played the game
enough it was easy to learn what the
common timings were but now that
everyone sees the same smoke and it
plumes vertically those days are long
gone now not only do all players see the
same smoke regardless of position but
the smoke can interact with the
environment in interesting all y'all on
Tick Tock doing those one-way smokes bro
you're so you're malding right now bro
you're so mad no more one ways next to
grenades the edges of smokes can now be
dissipated when shot through and in my
opinion this elevates the game even more
if you shoot through the smoke and see a
Crossing enemy that might give you the
time to readjust and take them out but
at the same time you can bait someone to
shoot through the smoke and then light
them up as soon as they reveal
themselves it's going to create a whole
new world of Mind Games now although
this is still very raw generally
speaking people seem pretty hyped at
least about certain aspects of this
function and grenades
okay bro bro you're blowing my mind the
same can't be said about the bullet
carving then things get a bit more
controversial grenades provide even more
tactical what is that okay that I don't
actually like whoever shoots first
through a smoke
loses that's kind of what that sounds
like if you shoot through a smoke it's
gonna puff up for you and then that
person's gonna shoot through the puff
and then you just die now I can
understand the hesitation some people
might have about the new smokes like I
spent half the video explaining smokes
are at the core of almost every Strat in
CS go and seeing a change like this can
be a bit jarring but getting lit up
through a smoke with an a1s or by an
enemy you can't see because they're
playing on the edge of a smoke
is not conducive to having fun in fact
it's very frustrating sure you can make
the argument that these things take game
IQ but you can also argue that they very
much don't listen if modesty of all
people the king of cheeky one ways and
smoke spams is happy about this then I
think that's a good sign
hello
look you have fun away
smoke looks perfect now to be fair these
new mechanics don't completely get rid
of smoke spams either it just means that
players need to be smarter about them
whether they're giving or receiving and
honestly speaking I think this all
raises the depth of the game tenfold
sure one ways are gone but so are sky
boxes and that's just going to lead to
so much more experimentation the shape
of the smoke cloud can be pushed and
carved by bullets
I'll come back in five years but with
this added complexity I'm actually
really interested to see how new players
are going to react CS go has always been
a pretty daunting game for people to get
into and now that you can interact with
the smokes that's just adding another
layer now like I said valve has already
included the nade trajectory tool but
I'm curious if anything else is coming
down the line to help acclimate new
players to their first CS experience now
next to how it affects casual play most
people are looking to see what the new
smokes are going to do at the
professional level we spoke with nothing
and he said that even though it's still
very early we can already see massive
gameplay changes yeah the smoke change
is an interesting one because
The Meta of like 1v1 just kind of
obvious right like throw an he grenade
and see a guy and shoot through the
holes with smoke and maybe
um maybe your Opera can grab a gap from
depth and shoot or you can grab a piece
of someone's movement because if you see
someone for a second and you see the
direction they're moving I've gotten
kills just seeing someone spamming oh
they're moving to the right and I kind
of prefer that angle I get a kill
through the smoke so that I think that
direct mechanic is very obvious that
being said let me pass the question off
to you guys the new smokes do you love
them do you hate them do you agree with
certain people that they should get rid
of the bullet carving aspect because I
don't I love all of it every aspect of
it
I think it's great more importantly what
things are you guys looking to
experiment with when you finally get
your hands on Counter-Strike two let me
know in the comments and as always stay
safe and have fun
Counter-Strike has always been an
accessible game because of its sort of
low minimum requirements like system
requirements for like PCS like you can
run them on like laptops and like
that but people are worried about the
new smokes and like what the frames are
gonna do and if that's going to like
hurt the player base at all now it is
valve and they think of these things
ahead of time so I'm sure they have
something in the works that this is
going to be like super well optimized
but then at the same time you also can't
like have it where you can like
downgrade the graphics so much that like
it gives people with lower Graphics
increased Advantage which has happened
to like a lot of games in the past